first of all would like to say a big
thank you for helping me past 10 million
10 million subscribers in YouTube why
have you got to 10 million because it's
you watching those incredible videos and
how do I pay this I'm gonna keep up the
incredible work and more importantly
start creating even more content to get
to 20 million but thank you honestly I'm
blessed because 10 million people that's
a lot of viewers in my kitchen let me
tell you so I'd like to take this moment
and apologize for absolutely nothing and
to help celebrate 10 million what I'm
gonna do for you now is the most amazing
burger could you know I love burgers
right when they said I was mad at seven
years ago in Burgas store in Vegas at
Planet Hollywood
again I silenced those critics by
creating something unique we finished
those burgers with Devon G butter so I
put this amazing mix together now and
it's a 85% Chuck and a 15% brisket but I
took some blocks of butter froze it and
then grated the butter into the burger
so they get that nice rich buttery
smooth flavor inside that delicious
burger now the secret behind any great
burger is in the grill crank that thing
up high okay always close that lit okay
keep it down that gets the maximum
amount of heat in there once you've
blended the burger season it beautifully
and then shape it okay I quite like a
nice sort of thin pate and a nice wide
girth spread the thick of the burger the
harder it is to get the temperature
cooked perfectly inside so be smart
nicely seasoned salt pepper a little bit
of garlic powder okay now you've seen me
cook burgers many times but I've done
something different with this one
because I'm gonna fry an egg like you've
never seen before because I will fry
this egg inside a mushroom and put this
beautiful bacon egg mushroom burger
together turn over the seasoning you can
see those little bits of butter they're
literally helping to make that pate even
more moist
now what's this season goose Lee again
salt pepper I open at the top of the
pepper mill to get larger flecks of
pepper in there okay on and then again a
little dusting of the powder
okay and they're lightly
brush with a touch of olive oil that'll
melt beautifully with the butter lit up
they'll go to higher heat to begin with
okay keep it really nice and literally
central now that initial crackle okay
that's just the butter don't worry about
that okay little brush of olive oil on
top okay and let them cook now alongside
that I'm gonna take my mushrooms season
those mushrooms again salt and pepper
inside large flecks of pepper okay a
nice little glaze of olive oil
that'll help break down the mushroom
these are beautiful mushrooms and the
flavor in these things are incredible
okay I want them turn inside out like
that there and there now pull the lid
down get the temperature back up into
those burgers okay and let that get
really nice and hot now my buns never
underestimate the importance of a great
bun okay the secret is to make sure okay
that you do not get that bread soggy a
light sprinkling of olive oil salt
pepper I want to toast the buns that
protects the actual burger and stops the
whole thing from becoming soggy turn
that around and toast
lots of planes coming over I'll flip
that burger you
beautiful get that soft butter okay
and just literally lightly brush that
butter on there that's gonna give the
patty a really nice camera zation and
the seat behind these pates is do not
keep on flipping them okay
the more you flip them okay the more
they're gonna break but get that sear on
that and really important now the
mushrooms have a look at this okay I'm
gonna need mushrooms beautifully okay
and you can see that that's shrinkage
now it's time to take place but the good
news is they are piping hot okay so
here's what I'm gonna do and just
quickly do my burger over to there
that's nice and juicy so put the burgers
up there to rest I'll continue cooking
but look that is piping hot there okay
you get your egg this weathers burgers
and we go up a different level crack the
egg and literally crack that on top of
that mushroom look crack
and then very carefully lightly season
those eggs on alongside that let's take
my bacon
okay now bacon get out nice and crispy
yes
beautiful now how do I like dressing
this burger take that sriracha to curds
mayonnaise and one-third sriracha okay
from there I'm a beautifully dressed the
bun nicely okay and this is where they
start sort of going to a different level
dressing on top and a dressing
underneath okay always keep their base
towards you okay to protect the bun I've
got some nice fresh arugula and because
of the fatty richness of this burger it
doesn't need dressing so I put the
arugula on there to help protect the
bread and give that nice little peppery
flavor now from there take your tomatoes
and slice them nice and thinly
usefully done on top keeping that nice
and round really important to season the
burger every step of the way beautiful
really important got that ready before
the burgers come out now my cheese start
getting ready without cheese you can see
the burgers are getting really nice
and done look it started them out
beautifully over that incredible burger
the bacon I'll take the bacon off okay
and then literally just cut that up okay
so hold that bacon together I want to
chop the bacon up nicely get that bacon
really nice and crispy and then from
there I want to sprinkle some of the
chopped bacon on that Mayo and the rest
on top of the tomatoes so this is a
really nice crispy bacon base with a
crispy bacon topping now for the
exciting part
look at those eggs first off lift my
burger sit that on top of my bun but
wait I told you we're 10 million
subscribers I'm not done yet
now I like my egg quite runny if you
like it sort of ovz then leave it in
there but that for me is beautiful now
the flat cap mushroom with the beautiful
bade egg and that one's gone to medium
which is fine that one there look at
that I'm nice beautiful twisted pepper
and then from there punching hoes come
on
that has to be a burger worth
celebrating ten million subscribers from
the bottom of my burger the big thank
you to all of you now I know there's
someone out there that's dying to taste
this Gordon thank you so much I'm
honored to try your ten millionth
subscriber burger I think it might have
gotten damaged a little bit in transport
but still looks delicious I just think
it's it's missing something like maybe
donut no lemon and lime juice I know
need some hot sauce baby dab it up oh
yeah
there we go there we go that's how I
like it
[Music]
now that's a burger so glad you enjoyed
it
but honestly Shawn seriously do you
honestly think we need [ __ ] hot sauce
on my burger are you kidding me all of
you thank you so much
god bless [ __ ] hot sauce really